c'est l'heure du journal de l'Afrique
soit il est bienvenu sur France 24 à la
une ce soir la France qui exhorte le
Rwanda a cessé son soutien au M23 c'est
la première fois que Paris condamne
l'appui de Kigali au groupe rebelle qui
sévit dans l'est de la République
démocratique du Congo une déclaration
par la voix de la secrétaire des tâches
chargée du développement et de la
Francophonie elle était à Kinshasa ce
mardi nous l'écouterons dans un instant
cette petite bouffée d'oxygène dans la
région du Tigré en Éthiopie la corde
cesser le feu signé début novembre
permet peu à peu un retour de l'aide
humanitaire un soulagement pour les
populations qui souffrent de la de
pénurie et de la famille les travaux du
métro d'Abidjan le chantier va démarrer
après plusieurs années de retard le
ministre français de l'économie Bruno Le
Maire était en Côte d'Ivoire pour donner
le coup d'envoi des travaux nous nous
intéresserons au tracé et aux
conséquences de ce méga projet sur la
capitale économique du pays reportage à
suivre
le ton était ferme et le message sans
équivoque la France a pour la première
fois demandé au Rwanda de cesser son
soutien au M23 le groupe rebelle qui
sévit dans l'est de la République
démocratique du Congo il est accusé par
Kinshasa et par un rapport de l'ONU de
bénéficier d'un appui de Kigali cette
déclaration qui a un peu surpris a été
prononcé par chrysola zacharu-pulu
secrétaire d'État français chargé du
développement de la Francophonie et des
partenariats internationaux elle était à
Kinshasa Aurélie bazarra kibangula notre
correspondante en RDC était présente à
la conférence de presse
la situation dans l'est du pays est
tragique c'est insupportable et
inacceptable ce sont les mots de la
secrétaire d'État française crisola
zacaro Polo qui est arrivé ce matin à
Kinshasa pour une visite de 48 heures
des mots qui font référence au déplacer
du Nord qui vous près de 140 000
personnes selon les Nations Unies ont dû
fuir les affrontements entre l'armée
congolaise et les rebelles du M23 et
vivent dans des conditions inhumaines la
France appelle le M23 respecter le
cessez-le-feu décidé lors du mini sommet
de Luanda mais surtout la France
condamne pour la première fois le
soutien du Rwanda au rebelle du M23 les
M23 doit cesser les combats c'est
désengager et rentre les territoires
occupés à l'armée aux autorités
congolaises les Rwanda car il faut le
nommer doit cesser son soutien
om23 il faut finir avec la répétition de
l'histoire de cette région la France
les soutien
apportaient par les Rwanda au groupe
armé M23 alors ces déclarations français
surprennent ici à Kinshasa car jusque là
la France était restée mesurée alors que
d'autres pays comme les États-Unis et la
Belgique avaient déjà condamné le
soutien rwandais au rebelles du M23 ce
changement de discours intervient
quelques jours après une enquête
préliminaire des Nations Unies qui a
dénombré au moins 130 civils massacrés
par le M23 à kishichet il intervient
aussi au moment où est attendu un
rapport du Conseil de sécurité des
Nations Unies sur la situation dans
l'est du pays un rapport qui devrait
être selon des sources diplomatiques
similaires à un rapport qui avait déjà
fuité il y a quelques semaines et qui
fait état du soutien du Rwanda au
rebelle du M23 et puis toujours
concernant la République démocratique du
Congo sachez que le Conseil de sécurité
des Nations unies a décidé ce mardi de
lever l'obligation de notification pour
les fournitures d'équipement et
d'assistance militaires le texte
représenter par la France a été votée à
l'unanimité Patrick mouya le ministre de
la Communication de la RDC estime je
cite que le Conseil de sécurité vient de
réparer une injustice visant la RD la
RDC
tant attendu dans la région du Tigré en
Éthiopie arrive peu à peu c'est l'accord
de cesser le feu signé début novembre
qui a permis de débloquer la situation
une situation humanitaire désastreuse
liée au conflit et à la famine Caroline
Lamboley
des personnes font la queue pour obtenir
de l'aide humanitaire certains ont fait
le conflit plusieurs fois
nous avons pris nos enfants et nous
avons fui nous n'avions pas de matelas
ni même des ustensiles pour cuisiner ou
boire nous cherchions seulement à rester
en vie des personnes âgées des mères
avec des enfants et bien d'autres ont
vécu des choses très difficiles et
beaucoup de personnes sont mortes
en novembre après deux ans de guerre le
gouvernement éthiopien et les rebelles
du Tigré ont concluant cessé le feu
depuis l'aide humanitaire retombe tant
bien que mal aux tigré beaucoup
d'installations de santé ont été
endommagées dans le conflit aujourd'hui
les consultations se font à l'extérieur
alors que les fournitures médicales et
la nourriture manquent
les enfants de moins de 5 ans souffrent
de malnutrition nous ne pouvons pas
sauver ses enfants qu'avec des
médicaments ils ont besoin de nourriture
et pour le moment nous n'en avons
toujours pas reçu là ce qui se passe
c'est qu'on donne les médicaments à ses
enfants ils reviennent le lendemain dans
un état encore pire nous savons de quoi
il souffre mais nous ne pouvons rien
faire le gouvernement éthiopien ni avoir
bloqué l'acheminement de l'aide au tigré
des milliers de personnes ont été tuées
des millions déplacés et de nombreux
autres manquent de nourriture
en bref l'autorité électorale en Tunisie
a officiellement annoncé lundi une
participation de 11% aux élections
législatives de samedi un taux
légèrement en hausse par rapport au
chiffre préliminaires de près de 9%
rendu public après la fermeture des
urnes
le ministre français de l'économie Bruno
Le Maire était en visite ce lundi à
Abidjan pour le lancement de deux grands
projets d'infrastructures dans la
capitale économique ivoirienne
l'extension de l'aéroport international
et la construction d'un métro il s'agit
d'un gigantesque projet urbain d'une
valeur d'un milliard et demi d'euros les
travaux qui devaient commencer en 2019
et qui a qui ont pris beaucoup de retard
le chantier a également été à l'origine
de l'expulsion de nombreuses populations
dans les habitations se trouvaient sur
le tracé du métro reportage à Abidjan de
ange nomménieux
Abidjan et ses embouteillages la
mégalopole de 6 millions d'habitants a
besoin d'améliorer ses transports les
autorités ivoiriennes construisent des
ponts développent les bateaux taxis sur
la lagune et vont enfin mettre la
première pierre au métro ivoirien pour
le Premier ministre il s'agit d'un
projet global de réaménagement
urbain on est non seulement en train de
construire un métro mais on est en train
c'est pour ça qu'on est dans une prises
qui sont des entreprises qui sont larges
de prévoir la construction de logements
sociaux de magasins d'écoles ce sont des
villes nouvelles que nous sommes en
train de faire c'est déjà mon quitter
Cocody pour aller habiter à Bobo ils
vont être surpris l'entreprise française
Boeing s'occupe de la construction du
métro d'Abidjan selon l'entreprise la
ligne du métro permettra le déplacement
de 540 000 personnes par jour en
couvrant 20 stations de la commune
d'Anyama à Port-Bouët pour cette
urbaniste un tramway aurait été moins
plus facile à construire nous avons
estimé que le moins le plus efficace
pour Abidjan aujourd'hui
c'était de créer des lignes de tramway
c'est à dire des lignes de métro léger
qui pourrait emprunter de grandes
attaques qui existent déjà 130 000
personnes sont touchées par les travaux
de réaménagement du métro certains ont
pu être relogés par l'État d'autres par
contre n'ont toujours pas reçu
d'indemnisation c'est le cas de nébier
bidiot un habitant de la commune de
Port-Bouët le devoir de tout un état de
protéger les habitants et de protéger
leurs biens c'est pas à lui de lui
brimer
et surtout dans cette danse des
situations comme celui-là la Côte
d'Ivoire pourra rejoindre le cercle
fermé des pays qui ont déjà ce moyen de
déplacement sur le continent africain
au Sénégal le patron du journal
d'information Dakar matin à de nouveau
été interpellé lundi soir une
arrestation en moins d'une semaine après
avoir été remis en liberté sous la
pression de la profession le journaliste
critique du pouvoir détenu plus d'un
mois après avoir été inculpé et écroué
pour entre autres divulgation
d'informations de nature à nuire à la
Défense nationale
Omar Sy est à Dakar pour présenter en
avant-première ce soir tirailleurs qui
sort en salle le 4 janvier en France et
le 6 janvier au Sénégal l'acteur y
interprète un père sénégalais enrôlé
avec son fils par la France lors de la
Première Guerre mondiale le film est un
hommage au tirailleurs sénégalais
méconnu de la Grande Guerre près de 170
000 hommes ont été enrôlés entre 1914 et
1918 pour Omar Sy il s'agit plus de
raconter leur histoire une première sur
grand écran que de dénoncer les
promesses non tenues et les injustices
de la France à leur endroit écoutez Omar
Sy au micro de notre correspondante à
Dakar Sarah Sakho
ça se sait un peu de comment ils ont été
traités après que les promesses n'ont
pas été tenues c'est des choses qu'on
sait plus ou moins ce qui est
intéressant dans le film à mon goût
c'est que finalement on fait
connaissance avec ces tirailleurs puis
on leur donne la parole on a beaucoup de
récits on sait pas vraiment comment ils
ont vécu là ça nous permet de rentrer
dans le détail de qui ils étaient
comment ils vivaient et puis surtout
quel était leur part de sacrifice aussi
[Musique]
incorporer africain du gros Niger du
Sénégal de la Guinée du Soudan vous
allez contribuer à cet éclatante
victoire
[Musique]
après cette bataille vous ne serez plus
des indigènes vous serez des Français
les liens de la tasse de retour au Maroc
les demi finalistes de la Coupe du monde
ont reçu un accueil digne de l'exploit
historique ils ont réalisé ils ont été
accueillis en héros dans les rues de
Rabat la capitale ou des milliers de
personnes ont escortées le bus de
l'équipe on va donc se quitter sur ces
images restées avec nous l'info continue
sur France 24
[Musique]